-Good afternoon
everybody and welcome
to this afternoon's
panel discussion,
Household Workers Unite, a
Conversation Between Scholars
and Activists, which
is a rare kind of event
here in the ivory tower.
I want to tell you just a
little bit about the genesis
of this event and then
give our stellar panelists
a much briefer introduction
than they deserve,
and then get out
of the way of what
I expect to be a discussion
that will educate, inspire,
and challenge us.
Household Workers
Unite takes its title
from the important book by
Premilla Nadasen, Household
Workers Unite, the Untold
Story of African American
Women Who Built a Movement.
And at Radcliffe, we do not
have events that sell books,
so I'm going to show it to you
so that you can find it readily
in neighborhood
bookstores because I
think you will want it after
you hear about from its author.
It's hard to overstate the
novelty of Professor Nadasen's
study.
And in fact, when you look
in the Harvard online catalog
by its Library of
Congress subject headings,
there are no other histories of
the domestic worker organizing
movement.
In her story, an untold story,
ordinary domestic workers--
maids, cooks, nannies,
elder care volunteers,
and other household
technicians-- bond
together to become not the
victims who sometimes pop up
in our headlines but the
heroes of their own lives
and the founders of
an important movement.
As Nadasen points
out, household workers
had long remained on the
margins of historical study,
and marginalized three ways.
Overlooked in histories of
the African American freedom
struggle, in histories
of the women's movement,
and in histories of the labor
movement in the post-World War
II era.
In Nadasen's capable hands,
the organizing efforts
of household workers from
the 1950s through the 1970s
become a kind of hub
that ties together
these three major
strands of 20th century
history in a truly
intersectional and revelatory
way.
Household Workers
Unite reminds us
that the home has long
been a central theater
of public combat,
peons to women's sphere
or the separation of household
and work to the contrary.
So I'm the director of
the Schlesinger Library,
which is the premiere library
on the history of women
in America.
And it's obvious why our library
would have an interest in such
a pioneering study.
But we also have a
special relationship
to Household Workers Unite
because important parts
of Nadasen's research were
nourished by our collection,
as you'll be able to read
about in this winter's
issue of Radcliffe Magazine
where Professor Nadasen has
written an article
about her hunt
for records of the silent
voices of often invisible actors
in our national stories.
Today's conversation
uses Nadasen's book as a
jumping off point
for a discussion
about the current generation
of household labor
organizing and its relationship
to this long history.
After Professor Nadasen makes
some brief framing remarks,
we'll proceed in
discussion format
first among the
panelists and then
between panelists and
this wonderful audience.
I'm going to first introduce
the moderator of our discussion
who will be known
to many in this room
and to everyone on this campus.
Rakesh Khurana wears an enormous
number of hats here at Harvard.
He is professor of
sociology, Marvin Bauer
professor of leadership
development at the business
school, the master-- a role soon
to be retitled in part because
of his leadership--
of Cabot House,
and the dean of Harvard College.
He is the author or co-author
of five books and dozens
of articles and the
winner of many awards
both for his scholarship
and his teaching.
His research specialties
include corporate governance
and leadership and the
sociological aspects
of labor market
economies, usually looking
from the very top down
and here having a chance
to talk about labor market
economies from the bottom up
and sideways.
The activists of
our panel title are
a trio of sheroes, new
leaders in a movement
with a long history.
The kind of people whose
papers-- hint, hint--
libraries like ours will
be collecting in future
so that researchers like
the descendants of Professor
Nadasen can tell their
story in decades to come.
Seated next to Professor
Khurana is Lydia Edwards,
a movement attorney at
Greater Boston Legal Services
and implementation coordinator
for the Massachusetts Coalition
of Domestic Workers or MCDW.
Edwards was part of a legal
and grassroots organizing team
that wrote and
successfully passed
the pioneering Massachusetts
Domestic Worker Bill of Rights,
which became law in the
Commonwealth last April
and for which implementation
began just in the fall.
With the MCDW, she
coordinates grassroots efforts
to implement the
new law, working
with domestic workers,
employers, labor,
state agencies, and
academic institutions.
She's been named one of the
city of Boston's rising star
attorneys under 40,
thereby reminding us
of her extreme youth, and The
Globe profiled her in December
as a Bostonian of the Year.
She holds two law degrees, a
JD from American University
and an LLM from BU.
She is currently running
for the state Senate, which
should give us all
hope for the future
of American politics at a moment
when hope is sorely needed.
Monique Nguyen
Belizario, who formerly
worked with Ms.
Edwards at the MCDW,
has been since 2012
the executive director
of Mata Hari, a political
community dedicated
to advancing the rights of
and protections for women,
immigrants, and
domestic workers,
three groups that often
overlap in the household.
A strategist and
community organizer
known for using technology
in the service of advocacy
and movement building,
Monique has spoken
on women's leadership
and empowerment, on
domestic worker rights,
racial justice, and immigrant
rights at campuses and events
across the country.
She is the recipient
of many awards,
including to name just a few
the May Takayanagi Making Waves
Award from the Asian
American Resource Workshop,
the Salt of the Earth Award
from Community Labor United,
and the Horace Seldon
then Emerging Leader
Award from Community
Change Incorporated.
She notes that her
drive for social justice
is rooted in her own
personal experience
as an immigrant and daughter
of Vietnam War refugees
who gave her a wonderful
education in the conditions
of the possible.
Our third activist and leader
at the left end of the panel
here is Natalicia Tracy,
executive director
of the Brazilian Worker
Center, the nation's
largest Portuguese-speaking
workers' rights organization.
Before heading up the BWC, she
worked with Edwards and Nguyen
as the Massachusetts Coalition
for Domestic Workers.
So an incubator of
both legislative change
and a new generation
of leadership.
In addition to her
work with the MCDW's
successful legislative campaign,
Tracy is leading a Connecticut
effort towards passage of a
Domestic Workers Civil Rights
Bill in the past
year, and she tells me
that there's reason
to be hopeful.
She sits on the board of the
National Domestic Workers
Alliance, where she
is Vice President,
and on the boards of the
Women's Institute for Leadership
Development, Jobs With Justice,
Greater Boston Legal Services.
She is also, somehow in
the middle of all this,
a Ph.D. Candidate in
sociology at Boston University
where she has been
lecturer in sociology--
or she's been
lecturer in sociology
at UMass Boston since 2010.
That's almost as
many hats as Rakesh.
In closing, let me circle back
to Premilla Nadasen, whose
work catalyzed this discussion.
Dr. Nadasen is
Associate Professor
of History at Barnard College
where she writes, teaches
on the history of race, gender,
social policy, and labor.
She is most interested in
the historic roots of visions
of social change and the ways
in which poor and working class
people, especially
women of color,
have fought for social justice.
She has published extensively on
multiple meanings of feminism,
on alternative labor movements,
and grassroots community
organizing.
In addition to
Household Workers Unite,
she is the author of the
award-winning Welfare Warriors,
which documents the
welfare rights movement's
claim to a basic minimum
income in the 1960s.
She is also a believer
in the power of stories
to change the world
and she has recovered
the history of some of those
world-changing stories, some
of them at the Schlesinger.
Please join me in welcoming
her and our other guests
to Radcliffe today.
[APPLAUSE]
-So I've been asked to
give a few opening remarks,
and I just want to start by
saying thank you to all of you
for coming today.
And to my co-panelists.
And a special thank you to
Jane Kaminski for inviting me
and, I think, for having the
foresight to bring together
this panel of scholars
and activists.
And finally, I want
to thank all the folks
at the Schlesinger
Library who did work
to put this panel together.
Yours is the
invisible labor that
makes events like this happen.
I want to begin by saying
a few words about why this
is such an opportune time to
talk about household worker
organizing.
This is an issue that
touches all of us
in one way or
another, and something
that I've engaged with as
a scholar and an activist
for over a decade.
The domestic workers
I have come to know,
through observation
of their campaigns,
through attendance at
rallies and protests,
and through the sessions
of legislatures where
I have either
attended or testified,
have all been integral to
my intellectual development.
And that is reflected in
the pages of the book.
For me, it's tangible evidence
that theory and praxis
are inextricably intertwined.
And theory emerges not
only from the ivory tower
but from the lives
of everyday people.
And as an example
of the growing field
of socially-engaged scholarship.
I feel enormously passionate
about this subject,
in part because of my own
family's history and connection
to this labor, but also
because of the inspiration
that I draw from the
worker leaders around me.
This preoccupation his
even infected other members
of my family.
I vividly remember
several years ago
when my daughter Indira,
at the age of six,
paraded around the house
with a sign that said,
dignity for domestic
workers, after I
asked her to clean her room.
[LAUGHTER]
That's not exactly
the message I was
trying to convey to
her when I talked
to her about the rights
of domestic workers,
but it was a poignant example
of how, indeed, household labor
shapes our everyday lives.
Despite the importance
of household labor--
and this is the cooking, the
cleaning, and the caring that
enables each and every one of
us to go to work or survive
from one day to the next--
this is undervalued labor.
People-- usually women,
but not exclusively--
are expected to
do it without pay.
In addition, this
work takes place
in the home, which
is not usually
considered a site of labor.
Finally, as a paid
occupation, it's
performed by immigrant
women and/or women
of color, which has
profoundly shaped
the status of domestic workers
in law and social policy.
In the 1930s, when basic
labor protections for workers
that we think of as
standard today were passed--
and this is minimum wage,
social security, overtime pay,
unemployment insurance,
as well as the right
to organize and
bargain collectively--
the vast majority of
domestic workers at the time
were African American women.
And the racial and
gender politics
ensured that household
workers would be excluded
from the realm of labor rights.
In many ways, the paid
household workers--
those people who we
hire to clean our homes
and take care of our children--
are outside the boundaries
of legitimate labor.
And their work is
often unrecognized.
Mainstream labor
unions rarely organized
to improve domestic workers'
labor conditions or wages,
and the common wisdom
among labor organizers
in the 20th century was that
they were unorganizable.
Indeed, domestic workers
are hard to organize.
They are what we
would call today
precarious workers, an
informal labor force
with very little job security
and with no benefits.
Because they work
behind closed doors,
it's not always clear
which households
employee domestic workers.
And even if we did
know, their workplace
would not be a strategic
space for organizing
the way a factory floor is
for manufacturing workers.
The occupation is comprised
of women of color-- sometimes
documented, sometimes
undocumented--
and English may or may not
be their first language.
And this is hardly
the image that
comes to mind when we think
about the stereotypical labor
organizer, but they are
labor organizers indeed.
So despite these assumptions
and these realities,
there's a very long
history of domestic workers
who have organized successfully
and won rights for the sector.
There was a national movement
in the 1960s and the 1970s.
25,000 mostly African
American women
that I write about in my
book-- they had chapters
all across the country.
In Atlanta, in San Francisco,
in Detroit, in New York,
in Cleveland.
Many had ties to the
civil rights movement,
but, as I argue, perhaps their
most important contribution
was redefining the landscape
of labor organizing.
They used storytelling as
a tool to organize much
like domestic workers
do today, and they
organized in public venues-- at
bus stops, on the city buses,
or in playgrounds.
And in 1974, after nearly
40 years of exclusion,
they won federal
minimum wage protections
for household workers.
More recently, in the
past 20 years or so,
we've seen an upsurge of
domestic worker organizing that
has pushed for bills of
rights around the country,
including here in
Massachusetts, that
is ensuring much needed
protections for the sector.
In addition, in 2011, the United
Nations International Labor
Organization established a
Convention on Domestic Work
that set international
standards for this occupation.
It's now left to countries
to ratify the Convention.
So this is an opportune time
to talk about domestic worker
organizing because of the
way domestic workers locally,
nationally, and
internationally are standing up
and fighting for their rights.
And contrary to messages
in novels such as The Help,
domestic workers are
not meek or fearful
but they are
outspoken and building
broad-based coalitions.
We'll hear a little about
some of the work that's
taking place today
from women who
are at the forefront
of this struggle.
But domestic worker organizing
is important not only
for the individuals
in this occupation.
It also holds lessons for
other workers laboring
in a neoliberal economy.
Workers today are
much more likely to be
independent contractors,
to work intermittently
or part-time, to not have health
insurance or pension benefits.
In short, an increasing
number of American workers
are experiencing the conditions
under which domestic workers
have labored for generations.
Despite frequent laments
that the labor movement
is on the decline,
household workers and others
engage in nontraditional
labor organizing.
And I would include the Fight
for 15 Movement, Uber drivers,
and adjunct faculty
are illustrating
that there is in fact a
growing, vibrant sector
of labor organizing led
by household workers.
And that sector, I
believe, is through
their innovative
strategies can point
the way for other workers.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you.
I really want to use
this as an opportunity
to really enable a conversation
and have the opportunity
to really do what Professor
Nadasen's book says,
which is to let people
tell the stories
and let that really be the
driving force of our panel.
But I have to say, I was
really excited, first of all,
to moderate this panel.
Thank you for the invitation.
As was pointed out
earlier, I've been
a dean for about
a year and a half,
so I've really been away
from my scholarship,
and it was really
great to sort of get
an opportunity to sort of engage
in such a thoughtful book.
And it also gave
me an opportunity
to think more deeply about
what I normally study, which is
the tippy top of the pyramid.
And at first thinking, why am
I being asked to moderate this?
But beginning to see the
relationship actually
between what I've
been looking at,
which is the top of the pyramid
in terms of labor markets
and labor market
dynamics, with what's
happening at other parts and
less visible parts of the labor
market.
In my own field of
organizational behavior
and sociology of
work, domestic work
has usually been sort of folded
into parts of the larger drama
and theater of social changee--
workplace demography or class.
And in many cases,
what's really interesting
is that-- a very famous
sociologist who was pointed out
in your book-- Lewis
Coser predicted
the end of sort
of domestic work,
suggesting that that was
sort of-- between technology,
social change that
was happening,
that we would basically
see the decline of it
in modern society.
That it was no longer
central to modern society.
That it was something more
associated with the age
of Downton Abbey
than it was now.
And it is interesting
to see fascination
with the upstairs/downstairs
aspect set back
in time, but in many
ways the mirroring
and the re-mirroring
of emergence
of domestic work in
contemporary society,
especially in
economies like ours
where inequality has grown.
To see some of the aspects
that we often would
associate with kind of
pre-industrial conditions
to sort of be reemerging.
I think partly
because Coser failed
to predict the
growth of inequality
and the slowing rate
of social mobility
that now confronts modern
post-industrial America
and the neoliberal world.
And I think as a result of
that a new emergence of work
on the nature of
contemporary society
finds that domestic work
has really become central
and reasserted itself, as
you beautifully pointed out
in the book on labor
market, stratification,
social movements, feminism,
and globalization.
I think from that, the
growth in inequality,
the decline of the middle
class, the differential class
positions of women,
and the division
of labor between--
increasingly we're
finding higher-educated
families married together
and how that is impacting the
nature of domestic work, who
performs domestic work-- I
think highlights, really,
that the domestic work itself
as a sort of system of work
can't be set apart
from an interlocking
system of understanding
race, class, gender,
and socioeconomic structure.
So I think this is a
really rich possibility
to really talk about
how a history like this
really informs us of
the contemporary world.
I think one of the other aspects
I would just sort of emphasize
before just sort of
jumping into the questions
is, I hope we have a chance
as panelists to discuss
the intersection of domestic
work on gender and feminism,
on class, and on
globalization because I
think those things can't
be decoupled in many ways.
And I think it's also a
useful reminder that domestic
work itself was
originally done, when
you look at the
sociology of it--
and there has been actually
maybe less written in history,
but a lot written in
sociology-- in some ways, again,
partly not because I think it
was explored ethnographically
or narratively the
way you've done
so beautifully in the
book, but because it just
was linked to the
stratification of labor markets.
And it was often lots of debates
about how should it figure in
to understanding the economy.
Does it count as work?
What is the sort of cultural
system that binds it?
What's the role of
gender behind it?
Because for most
of human history,
domestic work has
been an enduring part
of the social structure.
My understanding is
that the word familia
is derived from famulus, which
means house servant or house
slave.
So you can't decouple all
of this in any easy way,
and it's historically associated
with social structures which
are sort of relatively
immobile, confined, socially
defined in very narrow ways.
And as you point
out in your book,
and as we can read about in
the newspapers every day,
for many domestic
workers, especially
those that are sort
of completely isolated
and cut off, it's about
as close to wage slavery
as we have in sort of
contemporary United States.
For too many people,
they still don't
have even what
minimal rights they
have protected by the state
in any meaningful way.
And as you point out in your
work, how vulnerable people are
to exploitation both
historically but in many ways
today.
I think it's also
interesting to talk about,
when we say domestic
work, what does it mean?
Because I think it has a
wide-ranging definition.
For some it might
immediately sort of
be thinking about defined
tasks like cleaning or ironing
or-- but then it gets into sort
of more complex things of child
rearing and shopping and
where it sort of relates
to the family or the group
or the household within which
it's operating.
And it becomes sort of subject
to a very interesting thing
about what is the nature
of that relationship.
Is it on that range
from contractual to kind
of gemeinschaft at least in
its illusion that somehow
it has community elements.
Where does that exist
and how does that both
feed it's kind of continuation
as a part of the structure.
So I think this is all
really wonderfully rich.
I'm hoping to hear
from our panelists
on these and
obviously our speaker.
So I guess one question
that just starts from me,
I'd like to direct
and then-- what
is the link between--
for you personally
on this link between
history and organizing--
and what lessons do
you think history holds
for organizers especially
as we see sort of shifts--
and you were alluding
to this-- shifts
in the nature of our economy.
-Well, it's interesting.
I'm a historian, obviously, but
when I embarked on this project
I didn't fully
understand the ways
in which the African American
women who I write about
were invested in the history
of African American women.
And I learned that they actually
initiated a history project
in their organization to
learn about the history
of domestic work, and they were
organizing at a very moment
when the field of women's
history, and the field
of African American women's
history in particular,
was emerging as part of
the discipline of history.
And so they attended
academic conferences,
they talked about this work,
they attended seminars,
and they were very invested in
this idea of rewriting African
American women's history
to include domestic workers
and working class
women in particular.
But they also used history
as a way to organize.
They used history--
the history of the ways
in which African American
women have been confined
to this occupation-- as a way
to talk about how they could
imagine a different
kind of freedom
in the context of the
civil rights movement.
How African American
women can begin
to forge a new set of politics,
a rejection of the old mammy
stereotype that had identified
African American women
primarily as domestic workers.
-Is that something-- for our
panelists-- do you still see
that?
People using history as a way
of developing a communal story
outside of the African
American experience?
Monique?
-Yeah.
I definitely feel that history
is something that we always
start our stories from.
When we talk about our
story as in organizers
of contemporary domestic
work organizing,
it always starts with why did
we get here in the first place.
Because historic exclusion.
And we always start
with that story.
And along the way when we
were doing the campaign work,
we uncovered little
nuggets of history
that belongs as part of us too.
Like whenever we discovered
Melnea Cass-- and Lydia can
speak more to that.
Melnea Cass, in the 1970s?
-70s.
-In the 1970s, she helped
pass domestic workers' ability
to be covered under
minimum wage and overtime
in the state, and also the
right to collectively bargain,
which was amazing to us in
the middle of our campaign
and it really gave us life.
So that's one of the examples.
-So using histories of other
peoples, not just of the same--
and in the Brazilian, do you
find that or does it relate?
-Absolutely.
We always are standing on
the shoulders of heroes to us
as we look back.
Even something as recent as
the New York campaign, right?
So we're looking
at their history,
their process, their struggles.
How did they put that
together for six years?
And you build on that.
And as Monique just
said, and then you
stumble on different
pieces of history
that in the 1800s or early
1900s under the worst conditions
that people were able
to rise and succeed.
So that really starts to
energize the movement further.
-Also in terms of--
I mean, not just
on the ground with the
organizing of workers--
but also with getting what
would be traditional opponents
to understand why this
is now their moment.
This is their historical
moment to rectify a wrong.
And that was really what we
used a lot when we were talking
to legislators,
Republicans and Democrats
alike, to say this
group has been excluded.
It was an intentional
exclusion to the 1930s.
And it's now 2014
and someone could be
fired because she's pregnant.
Someone is excluded from
racial discrimination
under our state laws.
She has no place to go.
It is now our time to
collectively right this wrong.
So using the historical--
the legal historical faults--
to actually rectify and
make that a galvanizing cry
for the actual legislators,
it made them feel like a hero.
It made them feel like they
wanted to do something.
And OK, well this is-- I've got
to be part of the civil rights
movement, you know?
It was used that way as well.
-I think it's really interesting
how the civil rights movement
analogy is used by
lots of movements now.
And I think it's often framed--
when we look at the Supreme
Court on equality of
marriage, for example,
a lot of the use of the kind
of analogies have been akin.
But I guess one
question I have is
what's the limit of
using that analogy?
So one thing you
mentioned in your work
is that a lot of the--
in the 1960s-- a lot
of the women-- African
American women--
were using it to rewrite
African American history.
That in fact it was a
kind of dual project.
One was a kind of affirmation
of an invisible group,
but also this intersection
with academia and scholarship
to sort of say there's an entire
forgotten group who we have not
understood who played a
critical role in history.
How much does that
play for, say,
our new immigrant wave of
people who find themselves
in domestic work?
Or is it just really
the civil rights
component, or is it also linked
to some of these other things
about being seen as somebody
whose-- the history contributes
to a sense of recognition that
there's a group of people,
that there was individuals
involved who shaped
the dynamics of our society?
Does anybody want to
take that or-- how
much does that play a
role because you described
two components.
-Yeah.
The specific history of African
American women in some ways
I think foreshadows
what's happening now,
and in other ways it's
a very distinct history
as you mentioned.
And the legacy of slavery
that African American women
experienced was very
prominent in their organizing,
and so we hear references
over and over again
to the history of slavery
as it shaped the lives
of these domestic workers.
And so when we talk about
immigrant workers today,
obviously the context
is different, right?
There isn't necessarily that
same history of slavery there.
Maybe, but not necessarily.
So I think we have to think
about the differences.
One of the things--
I mean, I guess
there are a couple of things.
One is the question of
the lack of documentation
for some of the workers today.
And I think that's really
important to consider.
So we can think about what
is this historical moment.
So in the 1960s and the
1970s, the historical moment
was fundamentally about
the civil rights movement
and the politics of race as
it affected African Americans.
I think if we look at the
political discourse today,
it is really about the division
between quote unquote Americans
and people who we consider
not Americans, right?
It's between the
documented-- the foreigners--
and the domestic laborers.
Not domestic workers, but the
folks who are US citizens.
And one of the
things that I find
most fascinating about the
contemporary organizing
is the ways in which labor
organizers today-- and it
includes all these
people at the table
now-- have been able to
cross that divide and say,
actually, when you talk
about workers' rights,
it doesn't matter if you're
documented and undocumented.
That, in fact,
labor rights should
be entitled to people if
they're working in any setting.
-Could I just ask a
follow-up on that?
I think there are
examples of that
where we talk about workers'
rights as a universal,
but it does seem, and Jane
alluded to it earlier,
that within at least
our society there
is a fear of undocumented
workers given
the lower social mobility, given
the greater economic anxiety.
Again, I'm not an
expert in politics,
but it does seem at least one
thing people are preying on,
who are taking advantage, is
trying to create divisiveness
within the working class and in
particular around undocumented
versus documented.
And how does your
work speak to that?
Because I do think there is
a sense of workers' rights
as universal.
We have the United Nations,
the ILO, but unratified,
and contemporary
political debates,
and even within union movements
some ambiguity sometimes
it feels or seems like
around how should we
think about people who have
citizenship or green cards
and those who are undocumented.
And maybe some of the organizers
can also speak to that.
-I want to go back
to the other question
where we are talking
about connecting history
to the present, right?
And when we talk
about domestic workers
then in the past and
African Americans,
we also need to remember
that in the early 1900s,
the Irish, the Polish,
the Italian-- these
were the jobs that
were available to them.
In some cases, those jobs
were eventually good for them,
right?
So they were also
part of this history
that now a lot of the
workers are doing this work,
they are Brazilians.
They are El Salvadorians.
They are Hondurans.
So the connection is
there to the past.
I think the difference here
that Premilla brought up
is the immigration
status, right?
So that creates a great divide
between OK, you are Irish.
And you had papers, right?
You just had to get in
line and get papers.
But now there's no line.
There's no line to get
your papers, right?
So we have a broken
immigration system,
and we have 11 million people
and probably about half
of them are women and
I'm going to really guess
that a huge percentage of
them are doing domestic work.
They are undocumented, right?
And they are, many
of them, afraid.
Many of them don't
know that they have
protection of the labor laws.
Basic protections.
They have protection
against retaliation.
And so they are in isolation.
So they're in a
space where every day
they get taken advantage of.
Many of them are coming
in not understanding
any of their rights.
So we deal with that
on the day to day.
And of course we cannot forget
history because unfortunately
history constantly
repeats itself.
So we try to fix it so
some of those really
bad historical moments
don't sneak up one us
again and continue to over
and over again happen.
So I do think that we have to--
when we speak with workers--
we have to draw on history.
And we have to draw on our
own personal experiences too,
and I do that all the time.
I think one thing that
I left out of my bio
was that that was a domestic
worker for 15 years.
I was brought here
as a domestic worker.
I was in forced labor
making $25 a week.
Working 90 hours a
week for two years
and sleeping on a
[INAUDIBLE] porch.
And I shared that
with the workers.
That's my history, but also it's
a history of many other workers
that are doing their job now
and feel trapped and feel alone.
So we have a
responsibility to continue
to have these conversations
so we can correct that.
-I really appreciate
that because I
think having that link back to
sort of the Irish and Italian
and Polish-- that part,
especially in Boston,
was a very-- that was the
jobs that were available
and given the ethnic
discrimination that took place.
And I think just to
connect what you said,
I think we can't decouple this
from globalization, right?
Why are there huge
movements of people now
happening in ways that,
given the modern state,
what's leading to that?
Because there's
also, in California,
you can see people
coming from the Pacific.
And the Middle East has
become a place also.
So I think one of the things
is we can't decouple this also
from the larger changes.
What's happening
to our economy, how
we are doing immigration
policy, but also how capital
is flowing from one place--
-I just want to say
the demand, too.
We cannot forget the demand.
There's a huge demand
for the service.
I mean, the country now depends
on 2.5 million domestic workers
every day.
And by 2035, we're going to
need another 4 million of them
because people are
turning 65 every day.
And people are having babies.
But all of us
women, we don't want
to stay home anymore
and take care
of the house and the children.
We want to have a career.
We have the right
to have a career,
and we find ourselves
trying to have a career
and trying to take
care of the family.
But we're going
to need some help,
and we are needing some
help to be able to do both
and to do it well.
So I think it's something
that we need to remember too
is the demand.
And I think [INAUDIBLE] a long
time ago that we outsource
a lot of things, but we
cannot outsource our elderly,
our children, or our home.
Someone has to come and take
care of that right here,
and so therefore the need is
going to continue to increase.
-If I can speak a little bit to
the demand, also in connection
to history, and also the
connection to immigration
and how they're all coming
together, in a lot of the work
that we do it's dealing
with modern day slavery.
Human trafficking.
Right?
So domestic workers are
number two in the country
to be trafficked,
and a lot of people
don't know that
because they are unseen
and they're easily hidden.
But when you can talk
to an individual about,
you too have gone
through slavery, right?
What we traditionally see
is slavery being open,
out there, in a field,
and being oppressed.
And you do not see even
her as working, right?
You often can't even
see her as then being
a survivor of trafficking.
There are people who I've
represented who didn't even
know, didn't even
know what they had
gone through was what we would
define legally as trafficking.
And then the resources
that are available,
including a U or T visa.
So it is looking
at the connection
between our own slave
history and what
has become today,
due to globalization,
due the families--
some of my clients
were brought here to
work for diplomats,
for people who have
certainly the money
to pay them, and have been
totally exploited and hidden
away and not paid.
So it's the combination
of looking at immigration,
looking at the
globalization, looking
at why people-- the demand
to bring people over here.
Not only is it that women
want to work, but a lot of us
can't afford not to.
And as we say in the
movement, domestic work
is the work that makes
all other work possible.
Right?
And so for many local and small
mini-economies within the home,
the domestic worker is vital
to that actual family having
an income.
And so when we began
to talk about slavery,
and when we began to
talk about economies,
talk about immigration,
we have to talk
about trafficking.
And we have to talk about
that as a parallel track
to our fight.
And it galvanized
some workers and it
helps people to really
understand what they're doing.
What they're part of.
-Monique, do you want
to add something?
-No, I just-- it's just
a wealth of information
and I'm just trying
to figure out
how-- how to even connect what
we're seeing on the larger
scale, how to translate what
we're learning about things
these big economic
ebbs and flows
and why we're even here to even
use that as a tool to organize
on the most basic level.
And we talked about
the power of stories.
I had some students ask
me earlier this week
at Smith College.
They were like, if
there was "the man," who
is the man that you're fighting
with on a day-to-day grind.
Beyond the agencies and
beyond the isolation
of domestic workers
and organizing
across neighborhoods,
it's really the feeling
that you are disenfranchised.
The overall feeling, after
so many decades and hundreds
of years of being
ignored and oppressed,
that you can't do much.
You can't do much to
change your condition.
So the stories that
we come to spaces with
like, why am I here in this
country in the first place.
You know?
That's the main thing
that people kind of bring
to the table.
They're like, I
came here because I
wanted to send money
home for my child.
The most basic thing.
That was the only place--
the US was the only place
that I was told I can make money
and send home to my children.
And then some workers
really identify with that.
And other workers
identify with the struggle
of even making ends meet
to even pay the rent just
so you can go to work the next
day and have a place to sleep.
So our big question
as organizers
is how do we connect
the big level stuff
with the human level
connection stuff that we really
need to build the movement
to scale down [INAUDIBLE].
-I love that because--
and I am going
to apologize because
I'm going to just keep
being there because this is
where my level of analysis
always come from the structure--
but thinking about how we
connect structure and
agency is, I think,
where the possibilities
for change
are because
structure in my world
is that human beings
don't have choices.
So in sociology,
everything is kind of
over-determined
in a certain way.
We obviously believe
there's some choices,
but that there is
over-determination.
Your book points out that
there's agency, right?
There's a possibility
for people to organize.
And you gave a mechanism,
which is storytelling.
Storytelling somehow
can mobilize something.
A connection to history
that I'm not isolated,
that I'm not alone.
Social networks.
The bus stop.
These locales where
sort of agency
becomes possible
and collectivity
becomes possible and feeling
like you're part of a community
and you're not just an atomistic
kind of individual who's lost.
But I want to just
explore this connection
a little bit because
I think it gets
to the part of your book
about how do we move forward
if we're not able.
So just pick up on a couple
of points that we're saying.
You pointed to the
role of gender.
That, in fact, a lot
of domestic-- and I'll
just-- I don't want
to mischaracterize it.
But you have
situations, and it was
funny what you said at
Smith-- who's the man, right?
But in some cases, at least
what I got out of the book,
was who's the woman who's
employing the domestic worker
or, for lack of a better term,
the manager or the person
who actually organizes their
work, what needs to be done.
Part of this, again,
comes from opportunities
that as workforce
both-- it could
be both a combination of
both opportunity, which
is people voluntarily
going on to the workforce
or out of necessity,
that it's hard to lead
a life without having
to earn her income.
There is a combination of both.
But partly because
also housework
is not equally shared, right?
We know from a lot
of research that,
while this current
generation of men
does more household work
than their fathers did,
men consistently overestimate
how much they contribute
to that by way-off
percentages from what
I've learned from my colleagues
and from personal story.
So we still have gendered
division of labor
in the household.
And so we have this
very interesting dynamic
where gender and opportunities
among a certain class
of people.
And there was a
lot of discussion
about this when Sheryl
Sandberg's Lean In came out
and-- who was that a book for?
And who could kind
of be in that space,
in that circle, so she
basically was calling
for agency among people?
And who was left out
of that discussion?
And I guess I'd be interested
in just kind of exploring that
on your own
experiences because it
is, as we learn from the
book, a gendered occupation.
But also the dynamics
of who is kind
of organizing that
work is also-- I
don't think we could leave
recognizing the role of gender
there as well.
-I think-- just to quickly put
some comments on that-- one
of the-- I wouldn't
call it pushback,
but one of the surprises
we felt I think
in talking to certain
employment groups,
certain women-based
deployment groups,
was how the Domestic
Worker Bill of Rights
or the empowerment of nannies
or house cleaners for higher
wages, for overtime,
was not readily embraced
by professional working women.
Right?
Not readily.
I wouldn't say it
was a fight, but it
was a surprising
conversation that I had not
intended to have to
justify in many cases.
That you need to pay
your nanny overtime.
You need to pay her.
You need to have a
written contract.
And the pushback,
why, was surprising.
It was, so you can
go to work and so she
can afford to pay her bills.
But it was an irony because
I felt in some sense
the very same women who would
be encouraged to lean in
and to break down glass ceilings
in their professional capacity
as doctors, as professors, as
professional women were really
struggling with why do I--
I can't afford and would
I pay and she is just, and so
on and so forth, with my child.
And so it was an interesting
dynamics that I--
in one case-- the class
and gender dynamic.
And it was women who seemed
to have the hardest point.
Natalicia was instrumental in
getting a lot of labor-- men--
to come on board
to this movement.
So it wasn't as-- I don't know
that the push was as hard,
surprisingly, with
working class man.
So maybe there's a
class camaraderie there.
So just speaking a little
bit about the gender.
At the same time-- just
one more point about gender
and organizing-- at
the very same time
while there may
have been pushback,
the biggest proponents
who were employers
for equality and for
recognition were also women.
Right?
Who were professional
women such as yourselves
in academic settings or
professional women who
had themselves at one point
been domestic workers.
So gender played in and out.
-Yeah.
It's interesting.
Just to pick up on
your point, Lydia.
I think household
labor is simultaneously
the big uniter of
women across class
while it is, at the same
time, the big divider of women
across class because
there are women
who do this-- I
mean, lots of women
do it regardless of
your class background,
very often without pay.
Very often struggle with
their husbands and spouses
about who does what.
But it's also the issue which
obviously middle class women,
upper class women,
rely on employing
other women to do this
work for them when
they have to leave the home.
So in that regard,
it has the potential
I think to build bridges
among a feminist community,
and in my book I talk
about how that in fact
did happen at certain
moments, especially
around passage of the Fair
Labor Standards Act Amendment
in 1974.
But it also helps us
understand and think
about why there has
been such pushback
against certain sectors
of the women's community.
And in fact, feminism to
some degree in the 1960s
relied on hiring exploitable
women to do this work.
And the entire feminist
project was dependent
upon hiring women.
-I think that was such a
fascinating part of that story
because I think, again,
this interlocking dynamic
of movement-- that
you can't just
look at these as simple
cause and effect.
Where you really have
to understand how
they interlock with each other.
And the effect.
One thing-- and just want to
shift gears a little bit here--
is as you said,
and it's come out
a little bit, that
storytelling connects
domestic worker
organizing in the 1960s
and that it still
plays a role today,
that you tell stories
of exploitation,
stories of trafficking.
It's really interesting.
I have to say-- there's a
colleague of mine, Marshall
Ganz, who writes a lot about
the role of storytelling
in the United Farm Workers,
which is a kind of similar area
where you had people who
were really marginalized
and they were not
connected to any location.
So, in fact, it was
even more complex
and also occupied this
very shadowy labor status.
Help me understand a little bit.
Why do you think
storytelling is so important?
How it catalyzes agency.
As a person who comes
from a structural view,
the idea that the epistemology
of subjective experience
can actually move things is a
really hard connection to make.
Or is it just a correlate?
That we come up with
something happened and we say,
oh look at the roles of
stories in that process.
I think it would be helpful
to understand how it is,
and maybe you could
share a compelling story
and tell us what it
means to you and how
it might have affected
your own participation
or your own interest
in this area.
-I've always felt stories
are such a great tool
to break down stereotypes that
people have about one another.
Particular inside Mata Hari.
We're a multiracial,
multicultural organization
so we rely on stories to
really break down the things
that people assume
from each other
about each other in society.
The messages and the
cues that you get.
I'll never forget this one
neighborhood meeting in Lynn
where there was a
domestic worker who
is a white woman that was
making less than minimum wage.
And she's been doing it for
four years with a family that
made a lot of money.
And I'll never forget our member
leader, who was a Latina woman,
she was like, if that could
happen to a white woman, that
can happen to anybody.
Don't you see?
That was something that was
a breakthrough because people
assume that only certain
groups of people are exploited.
And I'm the only one.
You know?
Especially when you're
isolated, you're
kind of feeling
that I did something
wrong along the way and this
is why I'm in this situation.
But when you meet
other people and you
see the themes and
the threads and then
there's something bigger that's
happening here beyond just me.
And I think there's so
much power because of that.
Using that one--
your single story--
to connect with other
people and share experience,
and doing that to
scale, it's catalyzing.
It's amazing.
It's powerful.
-Yeah.
We see a lot of that
at the center as well.
Storytelling is
powerful because, first
of all, a lot of
the women, they're
coming in and feeling uncertain
in learning about the new space
and what's happening, but
also not understanding what
everyone else is going through.
And at the moment that you
start telling your story,
you become human again.
You are vulnerable.
When you open up and let people
know things that happen to you,
it creates a sense
of vulnerability
that allows other
people to respect you.
But also to feel that
they can share too.
We create human connection
and great human warmth
and create understanding
that we all,
at one point in time in our
lives, no matter who we are,
we are vulnerable and
we need each other.
And also the women, they get
mad at some of these stories.
And then they laugh at some of
them, they're so outrageous.
And then they'll cry.
But then they'll tell
each other that they
can count on each other.
And people leave
with the feeling
that they are no longer alone.
They are part of
something bigger.
They are not struggling alone.
And I think one story-- I'll
share with you really quickly--
it was this lady.
She cleaned homes.
And when she first started
coming to the center,
she was very shy, but
towards a few months later,
she was helping us
call other workers,
she was leading some
of the meetings,
and then one day in
one of the meetings
this lady was very upset
because the employer
made her clean the entire
tiles in the bathroom
with a toothbrush.
And she told her,
you know, I think
I'm really tough all the time,
but one day at my workplace
I worked really hard,
I finished everything,
and I thought my employer was
going to be really excited.
It was a rainy afternoon
and it was cold,
and because I finished early
she gave me bucket of water
and said, since you finish early
I'd like you to wash the fence.
And sent her out
to wash the fence.
She said she did wash
the fence, and she
says she cried the whole time
as she was washing the fence,
but after that date she
decided that why would
she allow someone to
treat her like that.
And she would never allow
for that to happen again.
And she was telling
the other workers
that when things like
this happen to us,
it dehumanizes us.
It triggers us like
we have no value.
We can't allow it to happen.
We need to work.
We also need to
keep our dignity.
So those kinds of conversations
in those spaces where
you have women who
are feeling vulnerable
really fill the space
with hope, but also
with the feeling of solidarity.
So it's really powerful.
And when you share stories
like this with legislators,
no matter how tough Republican
they are, they'll stop
and they'll listen and
they'll support you.
And they remember
some of their parents
who were also maids early
on in the early 1900s.
So that's how we're
able to get a lot
of the support at
the State House
was by telling the stories.
I told my story 300 times.
And then I brought lots
of workers and Monique
to tell their stories
too, because you also
want to make sure that
our stories are not
unique to ourselves.
This is something
that is happening
to a very large
number of people.
It's a problem.
It's a systemic problem
that we have to correct.
So that's why we
tell the stories,
and that's why
it's so important,
and I think will continue
to be as we continue
to now work on public education
and implementation of the bill.
-Just a note, coming from
a practitioner, when you're
representing individuals or
when you're part of organizing
but also trying to
explain legal concepts,
storytelling is vital.
No one besides a
group of lawyers
really cares to
hear about the law.
That's the truth.
That's the honest to God truth.
I mean, no one really
cares about the excitement
of changing the jurisdiction
of the MCAD from 6 to 1
through the amendment
that we did on blah blah.
By then their eyes have
glossed over and by then
it's lost the point.
And so instead, it
was learning from--
when I was organizing and
working at the Brazilian
Immigrant Center, working with
the women from Mata Hari--
is learning that if I cannot
communicate and just talk,
if I have to talk in legal
terms then I will not be heard
at all.
And so it was instead
turning my cases that
would come to me into stories.
So has anyone ever
experienced a position--
this situation where
you are working--
and my client, for example,
was sexually harassed.
Sexually harassed?
That term doesn't seem to work.
What happened is she received
a text message of a picture
of the man's penis.
That hits.
And then you go into
why that's wrong
and the feelings that come
behind it, and so on and so
forth.
And by the way, that's illegal.
Why?
Because blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
But unfortunately, if
you're a domestic worker,
we can't do anything.
What are you talking about?
Right?
And then that's the way of
basically saying the MCAD
does not protect
gender protection
because there's a number and
there was an exclusion and so
on and so forth.
So it was using legal
cases and experiences
that were coming as part
of the storytelling rubric
to explain rights, to explain
where there weren't rights,
and then why we had to fight.
-Yeah.
I was just going to say, when
I think about storytelling
and domestic worker
organizing, it kind of
reminds me a little bit
about the anti-rape movement
in the 1970s where these
were deeply personal, deeply
tragic experiences
that happened to women.
And it was really
only once they began
to speak out and testify
about their experiences
that you begin to see
a movement evolving.
And so domestic work is a
very isolating occupation
and domestic workers
are kind of invisible.
So we have this image of what a
domestic worker is, but I think
the moment that individuals
begin to speak out and talk
about their experiences and
you get to know who they are,
it's the basis for developing
a collective identity.
And I actually think it's
one of the reasons-- I mean,
this movement is so--
the contemporary movement
is so incredibly
fascinating to me.
And part of the reason
it's fascinating to me
is because of the
ways in which they've
been able to build bridges
across racial and ethnic lines.
And there aren't
very many examples
in history of a labor movement
that is truly multi-racial,
but this one is.
In nearly every
city, you see workers
of different ethnic
groups and racial groups
and linguistic backgrounds
coming together to organize.
I think part of the
way they've been
able to do that is because the
stories, regardless of who you
are, sound very, very similar.
-It's really interesting.
There's a number
of aspects that you
talked about what a story is,
that it seems to sort of invoke
agency, makes somebody
feel like wait,
I feel some sense of
empowerment because I'm
able to speak and to be heard.
That it creates empathy.
That a shared sort of
understanding and a shared
experience with
something that transcends
to a human experience
and not just
based on sort of certain
categories of identity.
Its connection to a
past seems to also be--
and that many
people, even if they
haven't had a specific
experience, in their families
they may have experienced pain
in the past in the past there.
They may have had
a grandparent who
had a similar role or a parent.
And then for some
reason it also seems
to get people who are in high
power suddenly feeling, whoa.
I think partly because
people in power
often believe that
they deserve the power
and they will use
it righteously.
And that somehow it says,
no, actually not all people
use power righteously.
And here is an opportunity
to use your power
as a legislator or your
power to sort of create
an even playing field
for vulnerable people.
Again, this is very helpful.
I guess some stories are--
not that I know anything
about the structure
of narrative,
but I guess some stories
travel better than others.
And that telling
your story 300 times
may have helped you
figure out which
parts lead to the sort of
moving people in different ways.
And how you tell your
story matters, and learning
how to do that matters,
and that's part
of what education does, right?
Education in some
ways is the capacity
to learn to tell your story
in a way that transmits.
You mentioned the
role of contemporary--
and I know we wanted
to leave a lot of time,
and I have to go
teach a class at 5:30
so I'm going to be taking off.
But you mentioned a little bit
about contemporary organizing
and I want to ask, and
it's kind of maybe not--
if it's a question that's
not working, just say it,
but in the beginning you talked
about contemporary organizing
among-- for example, seeing
the $15 an hour work.
The organizing
consciousness that's
emerging among people who
increasingly find themselves
in contract positions.
Uber or even you
UPS where you're not
considered an employee,
and discussions like that.
I guess one question
I have is, how
is technology allowing
people to communicate
across space and time and
how is this likely to impact
organizing?
Whether it's through
text messages
or-- what's replaced
the bus stop?
Or is the bus stop
still the place?
How do things like GroupMe, text
messages, joining a user group,
access to webs, the
mobile technology--
how is that going to play out.
We've seen it at least
partly contributing
to social consciousness and
revolutions in other places.
How does it play out
in social movements
and organizing here, if it does?
-I feel like technologies
of-- especially
for people that are not
used to having access
to smartphones, especially
as smartphones are becoming
much more affordable these
days, and now they've
become such a-- what
was once something
that was a high commodity
is something that's
so accessible for people.
And the power is learning how to
use it for your best interests
other than having your employer
call you to schedule something
and sending text messages to
your family-- nanny family--
pictures and whatnot.
Beyond that, there's so
many apps like GroupMe
that help people connect because
everyone is so spread out.
Not only are domestic
workers working house
to house to house,
geographically we
are spread out as well.
And with extended
hours of working,
you don't have time to really,
after a nine-hour shift
or something, go to a
neighborhood meeting.
So we have to figure out ways
to use tools to our advantage.
Like using GroupMe to
check in with one another.
And we've been using webinars,
and it's been interesting
because whenever we send
out invites to women now,
they're like, where
is the meeting?
Just call.
Just call us.
And we're constantly
having that issue,
but technology is so
amazing because they're
making modifications to make
it easier for us to even call
the workers.
So I've been using this
tool called Uber Conference.
That's no affiliation to Uber.
You can actually send something
out and it calls everybody,
and everyone just gets on there
like, hello, hello, hello.
And we're having a meeting,
which would take us weeks
to organize to be in person.
People are late for
different reasons,
tugging the children along.
So having a very succinct,
one-hour meeting.
We're going to do this for
this week, and talk to you guys
next week.
It's been so
powerful in that way.
And doing it bilingually, we've
been getting bigger, faster,
and stronger just by
replicating and practicing it.
-I want to say that indeed,
it does not replace, though,
the old-fashioned
bus stop and library
and stopping at the
playground, but it
does-- it's a great other
mode of communication that
speed up the process.
Even to check in on
a couple of things.
If you are at your
job and you have
a question about something,
a bill or a right,
you can text us and you
will get the answer, right?
So it does speed up the
process of communication
and give us
absolutely other modes
of accessing each other, right?
But it does not-- I don't
think that the old-fashioned
face-to-face and hugs and
getting to know each other
and listen to each other,
that human interaction,
we're not looking for it
to, but it does enhance
absolutely the work that we do.
-I would say a lot of my cases
I've gotten from Facebook.
Whether I meant to or not, I'm
just tagged all of a sudden
in a question by
a set of nannies.
They're like, I don't know.
Lydia, what do you think?
And so I'm pulled into
certain conversations.
Actually, one of my
clients who-- she was
brought here from--
so she's from Uganda.
She worked for a family from
Saudi Arabia who brought her
here and then did not pay her.
And so she asked to
get paid many times,
and I'm summarizing
the story very quickly.
Ultimately they told her to get
out in the middle of January.
They kicked her out of the
house and put her outside,
physically outside of the
house, because she just
wanted to be paid.
And so she is outside,
and she had her smartphone
and luckily posted that she
had been put in this situation.
From that post, I don't
know who found somebody in--
went to Uganda, knew somebody
in the state of New Jersey,
who knew someone in Rhode
Island, who knew someone
at a shelter, who got--
one, two, three, four, five,
and then the shelter called me.
So it was-- that's what it took
to get her to representation,
and get her out
and safe, but that
speaks to the power
of also connectedness
through social media that she
would not have had otherwise.
So I hope we can use
that as an example
to break down a lot
of the isolation
that survivors or people who
are going to trafficking have,
is that access to the
internet, which we did put
into our Domestic
Worker Bill of Rights.
You can't deny them access
to the phone or the computer
at all.
If you're the only
access they have,
you can't deny it to them.
That's in our regulations to
define what is for privacy.
And it's because of
that, having access
to those forms of communication,
technology is free.
-So we're going to
pivot to the audience.
I'm going to have to apologize.
I'm teaching a class
in about five minutes
at HBS, so is it OK if I switch
with-- thank you, and thank you
so much.
I apologize.
[APPLAUSE]